i'm going to take a quiz and find out
how irish i am
or i'm going to make my irish ancestors
roll in their graves
my mom did a dna test about two years
ago and found out that she is literally
50
english and 50 irish i'm descended from
the duke of
abbott who was an heir to the throne
back in 14th century my
great-grandmother francis came over
on a boat from ireland i am not very
culturally irish i have green hair i do
drink a lot of beer though
the answer is no not culturally irish at
all what is the significance of saint
patrick's day
oh god what did saint patrick do ooh
okay he's like santa's brother or
something saint nick the
catholics versus the protestants there
were snakes
the snakes are protestants it's a
metaphor st patrick drove all of the
snakes out of ireland saint patrick's
day is march 17th
march 17th i know that i believe it's
the second sunday in march
which of the following is not a place in
ireland duty's bottom
[ __ ] send muff clithro
or [ __ ] wow don't show my mom this this
is so dirty
okay this is the city i don't think
exists in ireland
with rose in england that makes sense
pronounce the following names
ah this is where it all falls apart
siobhan
shobin siobhan siobhan i know
that one i have that's how you guys
spell siobhan ma'am
naimy nam neve
oh of course yeah kayum no cave
kaohim malia
celeste cueva of course it is
spell the following names this is going
to be bad i
can't spell anything first name
[Music]
never felt so defeated in my life and
i've taken three bar exams now if i know
anything about gaelic
it's that the letters do not correspond
to the sounds
all or nothing sive
s i e
sive hold on
say it again who's right name three
irish celebrities sarah sharonin is liam
neeson irish
liam neeson bono oh bono someone from
game of thrones
cersei ronan is colin farrell irish
colin farrell do i get half a point for
just
knowing that the guy who was in in
bruges who's not colin farrell
is wait oh is colin farrell is he irish
yes
read these lyrics in an irish accent i
knew i was going to do an irish accent
there is not enough alcohol in the world
to get me to do this i am sorry
i mean i could sing this song let's do
it in the style of littlefinger from
game of thrones
oh danny boy the pipes the fights are
calling
from glenn to glenn and down the
mountainside
the summer's gone all the roses falling
i'm so so sorry it'll be there
in sunshine or shadow oh danny boy oh
danny boy i love
you so i did better than i thought the
song at the end
really kind of put me over the top hey
did they raise the roof in ireland
33-ish percent or so i'll take it
everyone who's watching from ireland i
just want to say
that i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so
sorry i really i do claim
irish heritage but apparently i have not
earned it you're a beautiful country
with a lot of culture
and you've given so much please don't
hold this video against me
you